ever want to buy a ranch that allows you
access to the top secret area 51
military base
well you better dig out your checkbook
yeah the medlin ranch the only
cattle ranch that is directly adjacent
to the world's best owned military base
is on the market that ranch is also home
to one of the most enduring stories
about area 51
the legend of the black mailbox yeah the
i-team's george knapp has our report
nevada's ticaboo valley is beautiful but
sparse
not the place you might think to raise
and graze happy cows
when a tough cowboy named steve medlin
first moved into the valley in the early
70s
there were no buildings no wells no
utilities
medlin and his wife carved out a 30 by
30 mile ranching operation
they and the rest of the world knew
almost nothing about the top secret work
underway just over the ridge at a place
dubbed area 51.
in the mid-80s though they got a crash
course that's when the air force seized
89
000 acres of public land with no
explanation
some of that land had been used by
medlin to graze his cattle
the military unofficially assured him he
could stay
they say it's never going to make no
difference and i'd like to see something
in writing
for that saying that medlin worked out a
deal he was allowed to enter the
forbidden base to tend his cattle
so long as he alerted them ahead of time
via radio
things became more complicated in 1989
when an anonymous man appeared on klas
tv
and said he'd worked at the secret base
on alien technology actually nine
flying saucers flying discs suddenly the
ufo faithful began
arriving by the busload in the ticaboo
valley among the visitors the anonymous
scientist
months before his name was made public
bob lazar
who showed up at the rachel bar and
grill in the company of a reporter
not yet known for ufo stories and a
wealthy businessman named robert bigelow
the bar later changed its name to the
little ailey inn
ufo visitors came to believe that a
black mailbox
installed on the highway for steve
medlen was the spot where bob lazar had
recorded his ufo videos
it wasn't and they suspected the mailbox
was where messages were left for both
the space aliens and the government
people thought oh my god there's got to
be the mailbox of area 51.
so they started opening it up going
through the rancher's mail
and of course uh the story was well it
really is not a rancher's mail
it's the mail to area 51. people opened
up the mail um
story is that the rancher even found
some of his pieces of mail with bullet
holes in them
in 1996 the black mailbox was replaced
with a welded bulletproof
white box it too became an attraction a
place to scan the skies
leave graffiti take selfies and a place
for reporters to record
obligatory stand-ups here next to the
infamous mysterious black mailbox which
of course as you can see is not black at
all
a few years ago the rancher moved his
actual mailbox somewhere else
and now he's ready to move on altogether
since late 2020 the medlin ranch has
been listed for sale
with an asking price of 4.5 million
dollars
that includes two homes 70 irrigation
spots for cattle
and 80 acres medlin and his wife are
ready to let someone else navigate the
thin line
between the ufo faithful and the
so-called camo dudes dedicated to
keeping them all out rachel resident
york arno is pretty sure
the legend of the black mailbox will
live on i already spent a lot of time
myself camping in that location because
it's
best place to meet people interested in
the various aspects
of area 51 and you meet
everybody from the military aviation
people the secret
uh black project people ufo people
and what better place to meet everybody
to form my own
picture of area 51. george knapp 8 news
now
the real estate agent handling the sale
told us in december that a pending deal
had entered escrow as of december as of
monday
it was still in escrow but had not
closed more information about the ranch
and its
history is over on our website